Sandra's stall seems to be a normal
healthy young girl she can do everything
at Playmates do but sandra is a child
apart she has leukemia cancer of the
blood Sanders leukemia has been brought
under control by continuous doctor care
at regular intervals she and her mother
go to the hospital where a sample of her
blood is taken the white cells in the
sample of blood are counted to make sure
that the disease is still under control
some scientists believe that tiny
particles called viruses possibly hidden
deep inside the blood cells are involved
in the onset of the disease that can
scientists proved that viruses are a
cause of cancer
and with that knowledge develop a cure
thousands of scientists all over the
world have been conducting research on
the role of viruses in cancer two of
those scientists have been asked if it
is now possible to prove that viruses
cause cancer dr. James grace assistant
director of the Roswell Park Memorial
Institute in Buffalo New York and dr.
Sara Stewart of the National Cancer
Institute discoverer of the polyomavirus
before these two scientists answer the
question it's important to understand
something about viruses and about cancer
cancer is a disease of the cells the
building blocks of which all living
things are made the rose robbing the
rhinoceros the microscope reveals
different kinds of cells that make up
the root of a plant or the muscle of a
man or the skin of an animal the cells
are more than building blocks they're
the very fabric of life each cell is a
biological machine designed to ensure
its own survival and the survival of the
organism of which it is a part to study
living cells researchers grow them in
bottles each bottle is planted with
healthy cells from normal tissue making
the bottle in effect a substitute for
the man or animal from which the cells
were taken
the bottle are added life-supporting
chemicals and blood serum for food these
colonies of living cells are called
tissue cultures some colonies developed
for research in the tissue culture
section of the National Cancer Institute
have survived in bottles for 25 years
the life processes of these cells can be
recorded with time-lapse photography
motion picture camera takes a series of
still photographs through a microscope
at long intervals of time events in a
tissue culture bottle that normally take
hours can be compressed into minutes in
time-lapse films we see that cells like
higher animals reach out for food
digested and eliminate waste and they
reproduce they divide producing exact
duplicates of themselves the simple yet
wondrous process by which the essence of
a cell can be sustained for millions of
generations is a definition of life but
sometimes the life process is
interrupted by agents of disease for
example bacteria which can be seen
easily with a light microscope it takes
the electron microscope to reveal the
smallest agents of disease known to man
viruses viruses are so small they can be
measured in millions of an inch they're
so elemental they cannot reproduce
without the help of a host cell yet
they're potent agents of disease these
viruses cause smallpox other viruses
caused tobacco mosaic disease in plants
these poliomyelitis viruses attack and
destroy nerve cells in animals and
humans these viruses infect and destroy
bacteria
is there a virus that causes cancer what
is cancer time-lapse photography can
show the effects of cancer on one living
cell the cancer cell instead of
producing normal daughter cells exactly
like the parent cell produces cells that
are sometimes too large too many and in
other ways irregular in other time-lapse
films by dividing the screen into two
parts normal and cancerous growths can
be compared on the right normal cells
are reproducing normally and in
sufficient numbers to maintain normal
growth on the left the cancerous cells
are reproducing wildly out of control
the cancerous cells are overlapping and
piling up on each other producing
abnormal tissue the result of cancerous
growth is shown in these two still
photographs of human skin in the
photograph on the right the cells near
the surface of the normal skin are
arranged in a normal functional pattern
in the photograph on the left the cancer
cells have broken down the tissues and
destroyed it several factors have been
frequently associated with the onset of
cancer like polluted air city dwellers
who inhale polluted air and cigarette
smokers suffer a very high incidence of
lung cancer but why not all x-rays and
gamma radiation can produce cancer when
atomic bombs were dropped on Hiroshima
and Nagasaki some survivors of the bombs
were stricken with leukemia but why not
all there must be another factor
involved in leukemia and other cancers
perhaps the virus how do scientists
prove that a virus causes disease in
plants as in all living things the
traditional proof of the causation of
disease follows
three logical steps first recovery of
the suspected agent of disease from a
sick host this leaf has been infected by
tobacco mosaic disease the leaf along
with other infected leaves is broken
down in a laboratory solution filtered
to remove large materials then
centrifuged at precisely the speed which
will bring down the leaf cells but leave
the suspected agent of the disease
suspended in the liquid above then over
a period of days the liquid goes through
many similar purification steps until
only the concentrated suspected agents
remain in the second step the researcher
inoculates a healthy leaf with the
suspected agent of the disease by
rubbing it into the surface
if the new host gets the disease and a
suspected agent is again recovered the
three steps of the cycle have been
completed
and we have proved that the disease is
caused by the suspected agent the
tobacco mosaic virus in the same way can
we prove that viruses cause leukemia in
mice dr. Sara Stewart will answer the
question following the traditional three
step recovery reinfection cycle we take
a mouse with spontaneous leukemia large
glands the biggest three and big liver
remove these cancerous organs cut them
into bits and break them up in a
standard solution we know heat will
affect viruses so we keep our sample
cold to remove heavy cellular material
we spin the sample in a refrigerated
centrifuge spinning up four thousand
revolutions per minute for 20 minutes
brings down the solid material and
leaves the viruses if there are any in
the apparently clear liquid we filter
the liquid to make doubly sure that we
have removed all cells with our cell
free tissue extract we inoculate newborn
mice
one of the reasons why we use mice for
research is that they mature very
rapidly and can be inbred to produce
special characteristics after 90 days
some of the mice which we inoculated
show symptoms of leukemia large clan big
spleen and big liver the same symptoms
of the disease in the original Mouse
finally we try to recover the suspected
particle and sometimes we tried to
substantiate our proof by photographing
the virus in a sample of the tissue to
prepare our sample for electron
microscopy technicians fix it in a
chemical washes embed it in plastic and
bake the plastic for 24 hours the
specimen is then sliced through within a
few millionths of an inch the slices
fall into a water bath are teased apart
by a brush with one or two bristles
the electron microscope is buried deep
in the sub-basement away from all
vibrations a tiny copper grid holding
the sliced specimen is placed in a
special airtight holder then slipped
into an airlock the barrel of the
electron microscope is had a near vacuum
inside a gun shoots a beam of electrons
through the specimen painting a picture
of it on a television tube where it can
be viewed or photographed by the
electron microscopist after thousands of
fruitless searches electron microscopist
have finally found and photographed the
very particle that we now know causes
leukemia in mice the photographs it's
magnify the particles hundreds of
thousands of times show that the
particles bud from the cell wall the
center is made up of nucleic acid like
the genetic material found in a Cell
the coat is similar to the wall of the
cell from which it is made the virus
pinches itself off and slips into the
spaces between the cells where it joins
other virus particles which are ready to
infect other cells perhaps causing
disease we know that 2 or 3 particles
sometimes joined like Siamese twins but
we don't know why and there are other
mysteries of the life and evolution of
these virus particles but we have proved
that they can cause leukemia in mice but
leukemia is only one form of cancer many
cancers are solid tumors can we prove
that viruses are involved in the
causation of this parotid tumor in order
to demonstrate viruses in this
particular tumor we must increase the
amount of the virus by passage in the
tumor cells and tissue culture
we inoculate these flasks with extracts
from the tumor of our sick brown mouse
exposing the healthy normal cells in the
tissue culture to the cancerous cells we
allow them to incubate for five to seven
days again a body temperature to
assimilate living conditions in a real
animal with the culture fluid we can
infect and cause disease in another
healthy brown mouse which develops
tumors of the salivary glands like those
of the original Mouse when we look at
the sections of his organs which have
been placed on carefully prepared slides
under another optical microscope we see
the typical evidence of cancer six cells
with irregular shapes and big nuclei
biological proof there is no longer any
question that viruses cause cancer not
only leukemia but solid tumors in
four-legged animals but what about the
higher animals the two-legged kind that
plays in the Sun
dr. James grace will answer the question
can scientists prove that viruses cause
human leukemia and other human cancers
at Rockville Park Memorial Institute
part of our research program is devoted
to the growth of human cancer cells and
tissue culture this one here is the
granddaddy of them all this is the first
human leukemic cell line to survive in
long-term culture this was started in
our laboratory in February of 1964 since
then we have grown many other leukemic
cell lines and we grow these in order to
supply our own researchers as well as
researchers and other laboratories
around the world we like to think that
we are helping patients like Sandra by
treating her disease but in a very real
sense of they are also helping us when
they first come to the hospital we take
samples of their blood which is full of
leukemic cells these blood samples are
then handled in sterile rooms to keep
them as free as possible or from other
diseases such as that caused by bacteria
the blood samples are then processed by
centrifuging them this brings down the
heavier red cells and leaves the
leukemic cells in the liquid above one
of the biggest problems has been to find
the best chemical medium in which to
grow the leukemic cells
we tried literally hundreds of different
combinations of medium over the past
four years
this one the 1600 and 40th one which we
tried finally worked
it contains 52 ingredients all carefully
weighed measured and filtered the medium
is then bottled for distribution to the
various tissue culture labs in the
Institute
several flasks of medium are inoculated
with small amounts of blood from
patients like Sandra and a human
leukemic cell Lian is then started and
hopefully it will grow a long term quite
a bit like not to making rounds of his
own patients in a hospital I go around
frequently and a look at our leukemic
cell cultures and see how they're doing
in the spinor lab we try to increase the
growth rate of the new cell line the
sperner keeps the cells rolling through
the medium by exposing them to the
chemicals and oxygen in the same way
that the bloodstream might expose them
to natural nutrients new cultures show
only a few clumps of cells but when they
were a few days old they show larger
clumps to get even higher concentrations
of white blood cells we use a
semi-automatic device which we have
termed a triple sell this solidly packed
white culture that you see here produced
by the troffer cell is almost pure
leukemic cells we can harvest as many as
10 million leukemic cells per cubic
centimeter of medium we will soon have
much larger troper cells which instead
of the 1/4 flask we will use 50 gallon
drums for growing the cells six of these
large drums will be placed on this huge
platform so that enormous quantities of
human leukemic cells can be fed kept in
chemical balance and harvested
automatically in the future these vast
quantities of cells might be used for
vaccine
at this time the cells are kept in cold
storage as much as 300 degrees below
zero for use by laboratories around the
world who are interested in leukemia
research one of the samples of leukemic
blood such as Sandra's might finally
help to resolve the question do viruses
cause cancer in human beings we
obviously cannot inject material from
her blood into another child to find the
answer but we can and in fact do send
material in special cold storage
containers to a research laboratory
where this material is injected into
animals which are very similar to humans
the monkey one of the largest animal
programs ever devoted to the search for
the cause of a disease is now being
conducted with National Cancer Institute
funds at the bioethics research
laboratory monkeys come to this nursery
within minutes after they're born before
they develop either immunity to disease
or any diseases themselves like the
human infant they are weighed after
birth but unlike most human infants they
are rushed into a sterile environment
the in on this environment through a
special lock that washes and
decontaminates everything that must be
passed into the isolator as quickly as
possible
they are inoculated with cancerous cells
on patients like Sandra they rapidly
become the healthiest monkeys in the
world healthy because they live in a
controlled environment with purified air
at a constant temperature and humidity
and they get plenty of tender loving
care
the nurses treat them as if they were
their own children and they also take a
formula that any pediatrician would
approve
any kind of illness brings the vet right
there temperature hopes blood pressure
and heartbeat are checked at regular
intervals for any signs of abnormalities
they're treated with kid gloves and the
truest meaning of the word while these
monkeys may provide the answer to the
question about human leukemia and
viruses on the sterile nursery the young
monkeys are then transferred to a
sterile holding room some of the monkeys
inoculated two years ago are so far
happy and apparently healthy but if
their disease follows a schedule like we
would expect in human beings like we
have observed with other experimental
animals and if the material with which
they were inoculated in fact contained a
cancer virus then they should develop
cancer at some point in their life if
they do we will then have completed the
infection cycle in primates the next
step and the traditional proof would
then be recovery of the viruses from the
monkeys with malignant disease this
however is only one of many approaches
there are other bits of circumstantial
evidence that viruses coached in the
leukemia this evidence is found in
studies in such deals as immunology and
electron microscopy at Rockville Park
Memorial Institute the electron
microscope has demonstrated the presence
of suspected viruses and human leukemic
cells
but what about the questions raised
today by people like Sandra's mother
mrs. Stahl I know well I think you have
been one of the really bright spots in
the management of malignant disease for
example about 1949 first leukemic drug
anti leukemic drug was developed the
average time from diagnosis to death was
about three months in 1960 this had
risen to about one year now the latest
count just a few months ago the average
was in excess of 28 months and and
climbing quite rapidly I see a lot of
people wonder if it was contagious or
hereditary based on our present
knowledge this is we studied quite
extensively there is no evidence that
leukemia has ever been contracted by
contact in other words there's no
evidence of contagion that one has
example mumps measles chicken pox
there's been a great deal of research
into the cause of leukemia now much of
this has been based on animal studies
and one of the most exciting fields of
leukemia research at present is the
possible role of viruses in the
causation of leukemia we know now that
throughout the animal kingdom many
different animal species ranging all the
way from the chicken upward including
cattle dogs mice rats and so forth that
viruses can cause leukemia more
importantly one can get these viruses in
goal of no laboratory these program
called Mouse leukemia it is possible to
prevent the leukemia by means of a of an
immunization procedure so this is very
important from a practical standpoint in
that if our viruses can be shown to
leukemia it is totally within the realm
of possibility that ones that develop a
vaccine which would both prevent and
possibly assist in the treatment of it
so the animal models are there we're now
waiting for the real breakthrough in the
human studies if in fact a virus is due
Cosima leukemia and since the human is a
is a member of the animal kingdom it
would be very surprising to me
personally if he had all the islands
that we know were immune to power or
causation of leukemia in the long
struggle for final proof many scientists
like dr. Stewart and dr. grace believed
that a viruses caused cancer in mice
they almost certainly caused it in
monkeys and Men the proof will be an
important step toward the development of
preventive vaccines and possibly the
long-awaited cure for cancer